good morning so before I get started
here um I was actually kind of thinking
as I prepared this talk I want to say
something which is which is that uh that
something about tooling so I was
thinking back like I've been analyzing
data in Python since about 2006 2007
can't really remember but that was that
was kind of pre pandas days where it was
all just raw matplotlib and numpy and i
was just thinking about how far to tools
have come and like just how
inconceivable it would be that i could
put together an analysis like what i'm
about to show you in that timeframe and
and really really even in the past
couple years there are things that I'm
using here which just make my life so
much easier
and so I just want to kind of say
there's anyone out there in the audience
who works on tools and puts the time
into that thank you
your work really compounds and makes it
possible to do this work and and have
the jobs that we have so thank you
[Applause]
this talk is in the general area of
business and analysis and specifically
it's about what happens when we stop
thinking about business results as being
kind of this flow of dollars and start
thinking about it as being a flow of
dollars that are attached to customers
and really analyzing from that customer
perspective and mostly it's about some
non-intuitive things about data analysis
that happen when you try and try and do
things in that way so we'll start by
kind of framing the question and then
we'll look a little bit at some metrics
to get some intuition and then we'll
dive into models and then look at some
results in the framework of that model
this is kind of what we'll talk through
maybe to frame it in the framework of
this hilariously bad infographic from
Harvard Business Review that is you know
being torn apart by the community right
now we're going to start at with
financial analysis which is not useful
and halfway between time consuming and
not time consuming to acquire and then
we'll move on to statistics which is
squarely in not useful and time
consuming
pretty bad graphic so yeah so to start
with this is mostly just like a little
bit of the the domain that we're working
in so that we know that we're right at
asking the right questions and answering
the right questions and it really starts
with asking like what happens when you
set the unit of analysis to be a
customer and you start thinking about
all the the cash flows that are
associated with those customers so like
when they purchase with you you see that
cash incoming you're spending money to
build or buy the things that you're
you're selling them so that's referred
to as cost of goods sold in accounting
more holistically than that you probably
have some some other costs which are
associated with serving that customer
this might be warehouses this might be
sales people whatever it be those are
generally referred to as variable costs
and then you probably spend spend
something upfront to market and acquire
new customers and so that's customer
acquisition cost which isn't appointed
at a specific customer but is kind of
like a portion across all customers and
then accounted to that customer so you
can kind of think about that in this
diagram so here we've got just money
coming into the business is above the
y-axis and then money leaving the
business is below the y-axis and this is
the way I think about it but I'm not
crazy about this plot because you can't
really see much maybe another way to
plot it would be as a waterfall so here
we've just got the y axis being
cumulative spending to date and we see
it ticking up as money comes in and
ticking down as many come money goes out
and so I kind of want to define the term
customer lifetime value in that way of
thinking about things to do that we're
gonna have to add something to that plot
and remove something from that that plot
and the thing we're gonna add is this
concept of net present value which is a
framework that's really common in in
corporate finance that we don't have too
much time to talk about but in a
nutshell we're going to take all these
costs over time and refocus them for
analysis today and we're going to do
that by doing something which kind of
adjusts for uncertainty and risk
and opportunity cost and those in those
cash flows and so this is just shown
here as being these these cash flows
getting smaller and smaller over time
that's not actually the cash getting
smaller small over time that's this
adjustment this discounting taken taken
into effect I mean this is just a really
common way to to take a bunch of cash
flows and summarize them into one number
and so in that framework customer
lifetime value is typically defined as
revenue - all those variable costs
including the cost of goods sold and
discounted at a company specific
discount rate I mean it doesn't
typically include customer acquisition
costs you may find if you work in this
that people may not be consistent about
how they define customer lifetime value
when I was reading up on this I found
this CAC was sometimes included and
sometimes not and maybe at the end of
the day what matters is is maybe not
that we all use the same terms but at
least that we define the terms and so
just just just a request that anytime
you talk about metrics please just talk
about what your to define what you're
talking about
the the reason there is about internal
consistency meaning that anytime we're
gonna do some analysis and that's going
to add up to some kind some conclusion
we want to make sure that we're
accounting for all the components in one
and only one place so if we're looking
at margin we want to make sure that
every component of margin is accounted
for and one and only one place and if so
will maintain internal consistency and
defining your metrics really helps with
that so coming back to this plot why do
we care about it I mean I think we care
about it because so much of business
analysis revolves around this mindset
and revolves around sort of acquiring
customers where we expect them to end up
above the y-axis
hopefully way above the y-axis and also
keeping up hurting our business that
we're keeping them there over time so
that was that was kind of the framework
that we're gonna work in I want to start
next by exploring a little data to talk
about the data I have to talk about
where it's come where it comes from so I
work at a company called second measure
have the data data team there what we do
it's like a measure as we analyze
billions of credit card transactions to
answer real-time questions about
consumer behavior so here's some
examples of some analysis that we've
done in the past so the first one is
looking at retention in the milk in
industry the second one is looking at
sort of regional variation in in food
delivery and specifically in this
company called waiter and the third one
was analyzing the impact of delete uber
on market share at lyft and uber
so we delivered this in the form of a
self-service analytics platform to our
clients and for hopefully obvious
reasons because we're analyzing credit
card transaction data we're gonna simply
look at lifetime spend and ignore the
cost side of the equation and so this is
not the whole story but it's definitely
a big part of the story so I'm gonna try
that thing where I define my metrics so
we're gonna be looking at lifetime spend
which is gross cumulative sales and
we're not going to be using a discount
rate in any of the stuff that follows
and we're also not going to net out any
of these costs I wanted to try and look
at this for a company so so I picked
Dollar General Dollar General is kind of
a variety store they had a they had a
strategy of building stores in rural
America where places like Walmart
wouldn't go and fun fact they also owned
eg calm after winning it in a bidding
war against Dolce & Gabana so when we
want to analyze lifetime sales for
Dollar General we kind of start with raw
data this is what raw data looks like
we've got time on the x-axis and every
dot here just being a purchase and then
each row being an individual customer to
calculate lifetime spend what we're
going to do is we're going to take all
those customers and align them by the
date of their first purchase and then
we're going to calculate cumulative
spending over time and we're gonna
average across everybody when we do that
for Dollar General we get this plot as
you can see on day 0 they spend $20 and
then over the course of about 3 years it
climbs up to $200 and when I started
making looking at this
making these plots I didn't have really
great instincts about how they were
gonna look and so I looked at this and I
was kind of like ok I guess so but I
didn't really appreciate how
extraordinary it is that you would get a
plot that that actually looks this
straight
which kind of hints at why Dollar
General is kind of a special company
they're exceptionally sticky so to sort
of triangulate that let's look at some
other companies um so if you got we've
got stitch fixed on the top left stitch
fix is an online subscription service
for clothing as you can see lifetime
spend is quite a bit higher for stitch
fix than it is for dollar general but
you also see this very typical curve in
in that lifetime spending data and that
is essentially customer churn so when
you when you start out one stitch post
starts out they have a large number of
active customers and then over time
people get get tired of the product and
cancel and so that's why you see this
sort of curving curving behavior there
another example being Wayfarer so
Wayfarers is a online furniture retailer
and the interesting thing about Wayfarer
is just that their lifetime spend is is
very front-loaded so they people spend
an average of two hundred dollars on
their first day and then you can see
spend climbing up over time from there
which is actually kind of a problem for
a Wayfarer so this is this is lifetime
spend this is kind of what we want to
reason about and so so the question is
why are we not done with this talk
what's unsatisfying about this picture
and the answer comes with something that
I failed to mention when I define my
metric which is that to do this we have
to align all those customers and then
we're forced to ignore people who
haven't haven't had the entire lifetime
of that plot available to us and so
we're actually excluding customers where
we have less than three years of history
on them and so that's that's really
unsatisfying coming back to this diagram
now I'm a data scientist I think of it
as my job to empower decisions and the
truth is is that you very rarely have to
make decisions on a plot that looks like
this realistically you're often making
decisions based on
plot that looks like this you've got
very little bit on on people and then if
you're working in marketing your
situation is even worse your reasoning
reason about people with no data on them
so you're thinking about hypothetical
customer acquisition cost and trying to
balance it against hypothetical lifetime
value so that's the essence of the hard
part of customer lifetime value is
dealing with incomplete data and to deal
with that we're gonna bring in some
models so the game plan is going to be
fairly simple so revisiting this raw
data plot we're going to build models
that are based on the past data here and
we're going to use those models to
impute data passed today past that black
line and so everything everything to the
right of that line is sort of going to
be filled in with expectation values and
then we essentially analyze the combo of
the real data and the expected future
data together as if they were the same
customer purchase behavior is fairly
multifaceted data you've got these
counts you've got churn behavior you've
got transaction amounts you've got
you've got dates and so to deal with
this we're actually gonna have to sort
of factor the problem into subproblems
and we're gonna start by focusing almost
entirely on modeling transaction counts
I like to I like to start these kind of
scenarios by asking what is the simplest
thing that might might work and when
you're talking about sort of modeling
counts of events in time the simplest
assumption that you might make is a
Poisson process this is kind of just
your classic first-order assumption of
of a memory this process that excuse me
um that goes on over time and it turns
out that if you fit these two data and
analyze how well they fit they don't fit
very well and the answer is in this
pictogram anybody kind of want to guess
anybody
the answer is Hasan's don't churn see
it's a it's a French French fish sorry
so you know turn is turn is simply
effective like in in business is that
people will be very engaged with your
business and then at a certain certain
point they'll just drop out and it's
because they either went to a competitor
or they left the space or they just
didn't aren't interested in you anymore
and so we really need to kind of expand
our model to account for churn so let's
ask what's the next simplest thing that
could might work
what we're gonna do is make the
assumption of some processes that are
happening but are unobserved their
latent all adding up to the data that we
see the the assumption that we that
people commonly make is that you've got
a Poisson process at the top which is
essentially going on until infinity but
that is filtered through a birth-death
process where any any purchases
hypothetical purchases that happen after
the the death date are gonna be
truncated in our observed data and the
name of birth death process here is kind
of taken from survival analysis and it's
just a codename for these kind of
assumptions where you assume that
something's going to happen once and
then after that thing happens you're at
hazard of something else happening and
then but that that second thing can only
happen once
aka your death and survival analysis is
kind of if we were in that middle
scenario and that was our data we would
be modeling time to event data and we
would be naturally using survival
analysis so you can write down the
likelihood that's kind of implied by
that probabilistic model and you can
infer infer that - we're gonna infer
back to two parameters and so the
parameters that we get out of this model
are the rate parameter of this process
on distribution it's essentially the
expected number of purchases per unit
time conditional on not churning and
then we're gonna have a second number
which is our probability per unit time
of churning which is called a hazard
rate and so you add those two parameters
together and you get this little graph
that's in the middle and this is
essentially our
prediction that this person is still
still in your customer base over time
conditional on the data that we've seen
on the bottom so so we know that this
person is alive until their last
purchase and then after that we're sort
of weighing the possibility that they
died
sorry turned or the possibility that the
Poisson process is just taking a break a
natural stochastic break so this kind of
hints at the hints at the framework that
we that we take here so we're gonna
jointly estimate a transaction count and
churn and then separately we're gonna
deal with all the other comparison
components of customer lifetime value so
when I first saw this framework I was a
little a little skeptical that it was
really necessary it seems a little
complex to have to do these two things
jointly and so I wanted to ask again is
this really the simplest thing that
might work to do that I'm gonna sort of
look at some fate some toy data and
illustrate something that might be
ideally simpler so this is a
hypothetical purchase history for a
customer and so this customer transacted
six times over the course over three
days and so we can just compute their
empirical rate of transactions per time
in this case we would see - and the
question is do we think that this is an
accurate estimate of their future
purchase rate and the answer is no I've
kind of set up this problem to be
intentionally a bad idea the reason
being is that were we're ignoring all
the negative space so there were three
day three other days where the purchase
the customer didn't purchase at all and
we haven't included those in our meme
and so that's why I would be
overestimating their purchase rate this
might sound like you know a fairly
fairly dumb idea but pretty much every
any time I go to do analysis I make
mistakes like this so so I just wanted
to spell it out here so we could compute
our mean again including these zeros and
get a different number and the question
is do we think that this is an accurate
estimate of the go forward purchase rate
and the answer is a little more subtle
but it turns out that this is this is
also an over estimate and the reason is
because there's more negative space that
we've actually ignored in our estimate
there so the the the sixth might not not
actually be the day that the customer
adjourned there might be simple simp
simply more days where they didn't
purchase just because of randomness and
not because that is that they're
actually turned eight in this in the
framework of this model and so we've
actually underestimated by not including
that little negative space at the end
and the tricky part is that that the
amount of that negative space is unknown
to us and is going to depend on that
customer's purchase rate and so this
kind of hints at why purchase rate and
churn are somehow entangled in a way
where we have to model them jointly as
opposed to modeling them separately so I
did I did a little simulation analysis
to kind of quantify this an analysis
where I knew the true rate so that I
could quantify how bad this bias is and
it turns out it's not too bad if you're
willing to bucket your data so if we
just roll up our data two months or
quarters we're going to get to a point
where we have a fairly large expectation
of events per unit time and if you're
willing to buck it to the point where
you maybe have like one or two expected
events per unit time then you might be
okay you might be in the six to 2% bias
range but you know that is actually a
deal breaker for most realistic
companies so I looked I looked across
our data we analyzed thousands of
companies at second measure and this
means that your bucketing at quarters or
years or worse and so you're making
you're having to make these very
coarse-grained estimates if you use this
somewhat naive analysis so yeah that's
the that's kind of the first big idea in
these models is to make this hybrid
probabilistic model but kind of composed
it from fairly familiar building blocks
from Poisson estimation and survival
analysis and these um these models are
generally referred to as counting your
customers models which is named after
the first paper where this idea was kind
of what's kind of phrase it formed
and that's that's the first big idea the
second big idea that I want to talk
about is something you'll come across in
a lot of these papers which is customer
heterogeneity so to motivate that I want
to look at these rates for these
customers so so we're just going to take
a data set where each row is one
customer and then we're going to
calculate the number of purchases
divided by the number of days so divided
by the time that we observe that person
for and we're going to plot it this is
what it looks like for a dollar general
so each tick here is a customer and the
first thing that jumps out to me here is
that variability is extreme so I've had
to plot this on a logarithmic axis and
the bulk of the data lies in three or
three full orders of magnitude so so
this is just kind of a universal fact
about companies is that the range of
activity of your customers is going to
be extremely extremely wide and you have
to deal with that another way of seeing
that is is to go back to this plot so
you know if you're like me you made this
plot and then you sort of caught thought
about customers in kind of orderly
fashion marching up this plot but if we
bring back the raw data and plot that on
the same plot with the average you see
that it's much more chaotic than that so
we have a lot of customers who appear
very close to the x-axis and basically
never never purchased with Dollar
General and it's being counter balanced
by a small number of high-value
customers so this is also just a
realistic fact you have to deal with the
second thing that jumps out into me in
this plot is these striations over on
the right hand side I'm not I don't know
if you can see that up there but but
this is these look kind of alien to me
it's odd that our data was so
organically perfect and Gaussian and
then we have these little ticks over
there like what are these so these Elon
Musk it's very high rate I don't know
what it is and the the explanation for
that is actually a lot simpler and
pretty easy to see if we revisit the
calculation we're doing and we split by
that denominator
in the calculation so we've got the
people who we saw for a very long time
up on the top and then down at the
bottom we saw people who we saw for a
fairly short period and we can probably
guess that the estimates that we had for
them are just pure noise so these models
have have a way of dealing with this
that is kind of motivated by multi-level
models if you're here yesterday for
shell rubs talk on random effects models
or mixed effects models it's a it's it's
a very similar idea mixed effect models
are kind of a class class of multi-level
models multi-level models are also known
as hierarchical models just in case you
know you don't need more technical
terminology um and so I kind of want to
motivate them in this framework of
estimating customer purchase rates so
the big idea in multi-level models is
that we can set up an explicit
probabilistic model that goes from
customers to events so that we have some
noise some idea of the noise which
appears in this data and then we're
going to rein in these very sparsely
observed customers essentially with a
prior in a Bayesian sense so so we will
regularize these counts to be something
more in line with what we've seen and
the novelty is that you fit the price
the prior is motivated by data and so
you jointly fit the prior itself and the
customer level estimates and that that
has the effect of basically choosing
choosing a prior which is going to be
based on this uncorrupted data up on the
top so I think that's a really powerful
general idea it's a way to sort of fit
really richly parameterised models in
this case we're fitting two parameters
per customer but still do sensible
things when we have very little data
with that I wanted to mention this very
cool library called lifetimes lifetimes
is a library for fitting models like
this from data I was open source by shop
Shopify
written by Cameron Davis in Pilon who's
a data scientist at Shopify and it's
it's it's a very easy-to-use kind of SK
learn style way to fit fit these captain
your customers models there's a variety
of them I'm not gonna go go into it too
much but this idea came kind of came
around in 1987 and then it's been
improved over time so if I can just be
opinionated I think you should use the
last one it's called the modified beta
geometric negative binomial distribution
and that's name from the assumptions
that you're taking on these
probabilistic processes and these that's
also what Shopify uses in their own work
to to sort of show some example analysis
I wanted to pick a different company and
I want to pick something with a little
more local flavor than Dollar General so
we're going to look at bird the scooter
startup in case you don't know so we can
we can make this chart this is lifetime
spend for bird but it's really
unsatisfying so first of all we only
have 180 days worth of data that we can
plot over and in doing so in picking 180
days I've had to throw out 90% of Birds
customers because bird is a hockey stick
we can we can kind of band-aid that a
little bit by cohorting so in this plot
we're doing the same calculation but
we're grouping every customer by the
date of the the date of their first
purchase and then plotting those
plotting each one separately and this
really this plot actually kind of
cleanly gets at that kind of missing
data problem which is that that our our
history ends today it ends at the end of
the end of the x-axis and we're gonna
have to do a variable amount of
imputation on each of these different
cohorts so our game plan is going to be
to simply fit fit one of those models
and use it to estimate that that
complete complete estimate of lifetime
sales I actually did something a little
beyond that which is look at break it
out by geography so bird is bird is
growing in different regions in the US
this is sort of a plot
new customers by month for the three
regions where they're operating in and
the the top one is red in red is the
West and then as you can see the South
has been catching up but but sort of
caught on later that has been growing
leader so if we were to try and do sort
of an analysis of customers spend based
and compare the South against the West
we would run afoul of the problem that
there's a very different mix of customer
vintages so the the South customers are
on average newer and so we don't have we
have less data and can't really sort of
naive naively compare them again we can
make this this plot and and you can see
from the plot that the South has a lower
average note lifetime spend than the
West but we can't really make a
conclusion from this plot in a very easy
way so to do this I fit one of these
counting your customers models and I fit
one model for the West and one model for
the South and then used it to project
out 24 months sales for a randomly
selected member a randomly selected
person in the population for these two
two regions and then we're going to do
that try to do that thing on the Left
where we define our metrics so we
computed 20 24 months expected total
sales didn't use a discount rate and as
you can see the conclusion here is that
the South has a 16% lower lifetime spend
than the West does and this is just just
to sort of drive home that that in
general the whole concept of customer
customer heterogeneity means that we
can't treat all of our customers the
same we can't expect them all to behave
the same and if your bird we're gonna
have to think about how to deal with the
how to deal with estimating markets
where we don't have much data yet
because we can't really assume that
they're the same as our other markets so
just to wrap up I know we're getting
late we're going late so so I wanted to
go over the core ideas that I spoke
about so the first one is this workflow
where you build models from past data
you use those to project the data that
you wish you had the near future and
then you
why's the combo of them and I found that
to be a fairly part a fairly generic and
powerful workflow the second idea is
that probabilistic models can be
composed of familiar familiar building
blocks and you can fit them to tailor to
situations like this customer purchase
behavior the third is to mine the noise
mind the variability of your data set
and the fourth is that customers that by
their nature will be extremely variable
and the fifth is if you ever have to use
a metric just just please define it so
here are some some references if you're
interested in learning more so we kind
of glossed over corporate finance but
I'm a huge huge fan of Aswath the motor
Inns lectures he's a professor at NYU
Stern and puts all his courses online if
you're interested more in multi-level
modeling this is a great book by
McIlrath for the counting your customers
models we talked about read up on life
times and also the blog post that
Shopify put out and then lastly we
hinged it on survival analysis and I
just want to slug a talk that some of my
former co-workers gave that is really
good about motivating why you would use
it with that said I work at second
measure a lot of our work is on our blog
so please visit our blog and read up on
it and as you can guess we're hiring
we'd love to talk to you and I hope that
this beside this this talk has given you
spark some ideas in your own work that
you can take thank you
[Applause]
all right very nice good talk is anybody
have any questions we've got a few
minutes for questions we're about 10
minutes early actually so when you're
identifying if the customers are
identifying the baseline credit card
number or a hash of a credit card number
a hatch of a name and a credit card
number or how they identified because
when I walk into with cash Dollar
General doesn't have my info right
that's true yeah that is a caveat with
the data that we analyzed is that it's a
credit card info and then we yeah we
generally just sort of we analyze
anonymized data but we have we have an
ID which refers to that person and that
person across their accounts hi thank
you very much that was a really awesome
talk I tend to use lifelines as an
alternative library do you have any
thoughts on that and one other question
I'm sorry to back into because I do a
lot of this work is how do you handle
what I call frothy churn which is where
you a user comes in leaves comes in
stays this is a prescription model where
they stay for couple months then leaves
and it's like they literally bounce back
and forth between these two states yep
yeah sure so yeah your first question it
is confusing so so Kimber and Davidson
Colin has open source two packages
they're called lifelines and lifetimes
and lifelines is for survival analysis
is which is when you're analyzing time
to event data and life times is for
customer lifetime value estimation which
is where you have individual purchase
events and you're trying to summarize
them into customer lifetime value so I
don't have it here but so there's a yeah
and and so depending on whether you have
a subscription or a non subscription
business and you might make the choice
of going one way or the other
because and so in in the literature they
refer to this as contractual and
non-contractual and what we're talking
about here is really the non-contractual
case where you can make a purchase at
any given time if you're in the
contractual setting you might be
analyzing this differently and
if you want to sort of have that that
model where people can people can in
effect churn and then unsure nor
resurrect you might be looking at
something like a you know hidden Markov
model or something like that so I don't
I don't have a ton of experience with
that and then in the non-contractual
setting that I'm talking about here it's
very common to sort of assume only one
churn event other questions hi thanks
for the talk this this was great I I
follow second measures blog actually
quite a bit I do work in subscription
models and awesome as well question for
you though around your data the raw data
do you guys how well do you understand
like the bias that's in like because my
understanding is is you have a set of
credit card transaction data that's some
sample of like all customers all
transactions and then what kind of
analysis how well do you understand that
as far as like this as a sample of the
population and what biases might be in
there and yep and things like that yeah
good question so it's a it's a huge
topic and something that we have to be
really good at I didn't really talk
about it here but that kind of hints it
why I mentioned social scientists here
is that you know there is a field that
has to do with doesn't start with the
assumption that your data is
representative an iid and we have to
worry about that a lot and so basically
it's just sort of like understanding
understanding and modeling out
quantifying what we think the
representativeness might be with respect
to some other reference data and then
attempting to adjust for that using
social science methods other questions
upfront maybe
whatever you found to be the performance
limitations of lifetime good question
yeah so these models jump through fair
amount of Hoops to to attain scalability
the main strategy they take is that we
don't need to feed it a data frame where
each row is a purchase we kind of
summarize to a customer and then for
that customer we calculate these three
stuff sufficient statistics and then you
fit the model using maximum likelihood
so I don't have hard numbers on where
them where the model kind of breaks or
where it where it fails to scale but in
a rough in a rough ballpark I can fit
models on my laptop with a hundred
thousand customers which is like a
fairly fairly large company in a couple
seconds and I get the sense that sort of
you go a couple order magnitudes beyond
that you're gonna be talking about
problems and I know that Shopify also
rode up a little bit on how they deal
with scalability and they have a pretty
big data problem so you could read their
blog we have time for two more questions
any more questions all right thank you
let's give everybody so much head to her
great talk
[Applause]